Toronto Raptors finally got their
championship rings last night at their
season opening game and it's the biggest
ring the NBA has ever created and
someone who isn't on the team showed off
his as well all right so there's Drake
showing off his bling so Drake got the
championship ring but he also got Jason
of Beverly Hills to design a second ring
just for him to commemorate the winning
season we also have video of Drake
showing it off as well so that's the
championship ring on his pinky finger
with the North written on it and then
the custom ring just for Drake is the
one with the Raptor on it on his ring
finger as the Kyle Lowry was showing it
off before the game as well last night
he was very involved in the design of
the ring there is right there so some
details about it the face has 74
diamonds on it to represent the 74 wins
the team had last season it's got the
same power on there
there are about 650 diamonds on it in
total depending on the finger size it's
14 carats in total how really wanted to
make sure represented the team and the
city that is a huge that's it obviously
large ring like am I wrong in this like
our other championship rings the same
sort of size is that like are they as
girthy on people's hands I mean it's
like I know they make large rings
because athletes themselves are large
right but the proportion of ring to
knuckle seems obnoxiously large to me ah
yeah it's not a ring I don't think
people ever actually wear those rings
around like right do any I don't think
like it looks like it looks like you're
wearing a cactus on your head right
right champions one is the one yeah it's
like look how big it is on because color
is like six-foot tall like yeah I think
that looks on his head like that's tough
me dangerous did someone with that faces
I don't think drinks should have gotten
a ring he doesn't play basketball oh
great there's a lot of people that get
the rings like the entire Wrather staff
gets one like all the training goin so
three is involved with the organization
Isis funny that he wasn't made his own
no did he not know that he was gonna get
one like maybe they were on the fence be
like listen if we have one left over bro
okay like I don't know we can't say
right now Jimin says oMG it's the size
of a smart car it is yes it's thank you
for that oh man
going after he says Drake wants to be
involved in Lilly everything except his
son's life obviously have a ring when he
best play for the team get this clown a
dunce cap hold on a second no but he was
paid by the Raptors right like is he not
still there Global and bad I don't know
if he still has that title or not
because that's a few years right if he
still has that title I would assume so
yeah it still is that they don't correct
me if people who are paid and believe me
Drake has done a lot for the Raptors I'm
not saying the man has not done a lot
for the Raptors like right there's you
know there's a reason he has those seats
and he's allowed to do what he's allowed
to do and whatever he's making your own
ring was weird I found that weird i
curious is the amount of money that's
spent on those rings is enough to
provide shelter for the homeless what's
just true yeah I don't see what was the
point of this jewelry yeah every team
gets yeah Glenn says was happy to
receive a replica ring at the game last
night yeah so you can't get around the
ring I know how much they are I haven't
heard how much the replica Rings are but
yeah you can get one that's guys I made
my own that's like when all your kids
you know were on Halloween like when all
your friends were like stormtroopers or
something like that or whatever it was
and you didn't get a stormtrooper
costume so like your mom made you one
you know what I mean and like you still
wanted to be like a stormtrooper with
your friends and your friends are cool
and they let you but you're the guy with
the homemade stormtrooper outfit when
all your friends had like the real cool
stormtrooper outfit yeah like to have a
second ring like isn't it cooler that
you've got one of the Raptors that's
what I'm saying yeah I made my own yeah
and I understand if Drake made those
rings that also gave those to everybody
on the team I didn't he didn't though